welcome to this video size
very much from the chess de
and also the
subscribers to my youtube channel to
this video the first about the
dortmund chess days 2012 already the
fortieth edition and i think we
can look forward to an interesting tournament
this time  selected line-up
ten players, four of them german
participants, the four winners
of last year's european team championship
actually promises interesting games and
yes, yes, a lot of fighting chess because this
year too, earlier draws are forbidden
so let's go straight to the game of the
first round which i
I actually plan to make a game of the day for each round
it's really so boring that I ca
n't find anything but I think we can be
quite optimistic that there's always
something to watch yes I chose for the first
round  the
game caruana suffers against yes here meet
each other  he
two very interesting players
caruana yes one of the shooting stars of this year
meanwhile
established among the top ten in the world
i'm not quite sure which
place he has maybe sixth or
seventh place according to the number i
think that's right and has been suffering from the known
german number for years  one
has been many years now i think
definitely four five six years and
also successfully participated in
the last editions on thursdays yes
riots has white and opened the four
is already on the board your
plays pretty much every opening at
most later ran here
suffers answers here with i5 he also has
a flexible repair at 5 comes very
often and
we see a scottish party here
that wasn't necessarily to be
expected caruana usually plays
spanish which seems to be the most popular on the level but here it comes
to scottish as said  also i think
an interesting choice for the viewers
it is often has here that the forces
collide and that fell
so much tactical mediation there are
blacks in the district of schwandorf has 25
one of the two main variations in the
other game today karjakin against
kramnik six knights were played the
two moves are about equally popular
would be  but i also say
quite different
positions
hannover 25 came and kavala late now jumper
b 3 here white has quite a
large selection the other main moves
here are loose e3 hoops runners who hit
three
or jumper hits them six both
also very popular
the feeder b 3 was  something fell into
oblivion until carlsen dug
up about two years and three years ago i
think stood two years 2010 against
agro and yes at that time
certainly still the fruit of the
cooperation with kasparow and the
sugar gained some popularity afterwards
we can see why that
is because  the position that arises
is very interesting  sant are black play
knight bishop up to six because previously
attacked even as the three jumps
11 6 everything is normal and now the 2
the idea of ​​dami 2 is that we can see
now painted black
and white plays bishop after e3 in the
mentioned carlsen patient macro
by the way came bishop g5
but running three is also quite
interesting now we see the idea of
this setup with queen two white
so want to quickly neutralize the bishop on the six
here and
aim for the long okada here as quickly as possible
so quickly remove the king
from the center here and  then
on the line yes to stand against the black
queen and black make the move the
75 more difficult we see that black
now first tomi eight plays
certainly a plausible move drive the
pawns the four on which
now needs protection as an
example the f3
yes and now  an interesting move by
black whose at least world
database since the bosses
online database kom  plettes neu ist
avoids now playing the five
that seems pretty
risky to me, but it was certainly not
invented on the board, it was checked
by
machine beforehand that it
really works
the sticking point here is or maybe I
just briefly what has been
played so far  black has been
satisfied here with such
variations black takes on the 3 and
plays the
6 now there aren't exactly hundreds of
games but maybe just
half a dozen or slightly more so it
's relative here
are already relative and well-
trodden paths here and that makes the difference  also the appeal of
this variation proves that you can
bring something new relatively early on or here even black
can bring something new so not exactly
20 theory moves and then look at
the and its okay i would both
know the draw  so is black
now open the center with the 52
reply with the long straight one
of course the critical move has to
be now the d line
here is a problem for black as he
is in the pin in here
and the pawn d5 now becomes a
problem here black actually has
two options now he can protect it
follower your sex what he played
an alternative would be the
quite right one to bring the 4 and these cables
here to the two figures
on c 303,
however, through this fortress in
which black of course does not threaten
to hit and white has the opportunity
to play something like back
then when the whole thing is very
complicated i'll just give you an
example the once
black
bishop develops you 62 plays
bishop b5 attacking the sprinter c6 to
increase the pressure on the pawn the four
here that could be for example
continue like this
just as an example variant and the
whole story will come out pretty
unclear before
well the game will be terrible
complicated you shouldn't
stay too long in the variations here
but the four was definitely
an alternative worth considering but of
course it's pretty cheeky
looking admittedly yes black plays bishop e6 and
white now we have
to show it twice briefly because it can also be done
quite a bit by itself  hard fell grab if
he takes for example here then yes
win black follower bad five
save because the bishop i3 he
gets terribly under pressure runs b6 and the tumor
48 are on the bishop i3 and
something like that ends very embarrassing so white ca
n't hit the five there  you now
28 still a good move because he also
moves out of the atom line from
black here the line goes out
so it's definitely a reasonable move
yes black plays knight you 5
that makes sense too i
think i might also play c7 c6
to prepare
and also on the staff 4,
for example, springer had fruit in
the springer against
deswe's disposal  gen white also plays h3 now here to
prepare the sugar 4
so as not to kick the knight here so that the knight keeps it on 45
yes what does black play now he has
played springer ag 6
and i think that is questionable
however everything should be enjoyed with caution
the whole  story is very
complicated
it seems to me that black would have
better captured here on 3 the
three jumpers g6 the difference is that
now the queen is in the
file the a file is not open what was in the
game against play
point
that could go on like this five  springer
has
hours then takes the field and white
plays with the idea of ​​hafen
the whole thing also looks a bit better
refers so how does this whole idea
with the five in the
opening seem a bit dangerous for
black but
who knows maybe because it is
quite good but it seems more dangerous
as I said he didn't play like that
so black didn't take like three
but is  t immediately went to g6
so white could now capture and make the
staff four there is of course
a difference now and
simply f4 fulfilled with pieces win
with fork cascades on your six
jumps on g6 and
black doesn’t exactly have many moves
around that  to prevent it is a
bit squeezed at the end he played
the 7 otherwise
simply r5 comes and one piece is gone so there is
hardly an alternative to this move yes
and now white simply plays five
knights e5 eb-5 compared to the
position the same  which I just
showed follower dash t3 at first it seems to
me that it is still much worse to
accept in comparison
white has a pawn more to everything
so black I think she has problems in any
case and he only has the
choice between different
problematic positions but  Here, as
I said, there is
also a problem with the creation of a
farmer - so
try it now suffers from a  uch to get a direct counterplay straight away
I think
it's reasonable to attack 5 with two the
5 b 410 knight shown here on c3
and
then to come up with thomas two
and principles is the second idea
proves must above all serve like four
and therefore plays a3 no
great alternative to it and now plays
suffers straight runner knight c4
activates the knight white
can't leave him standing he takes
away the dirt and
black back he white makes
very strong now so I was wondering here
why not knight  the four when I
played that knight the two that
's really good hour I had a
track move here that actually caught my
eye more directly because why not
pull the knight into the center here but
black has an amazingly strong move
that you can't even see right away  at least
not
sees damacht is remarkably strong with
the idea of ​​preferring
b5 b4 and black to the pawns up to b4  z opens her the bellini
it's
funny that it's
really not at all clear what's
happening here when white, for example,
tries to attack himself with g4 g5
g5 then black comes with b4 and
blitz but it gets extremely hairy, for
example when white hits the move
jump here
sprinkler hits
tomi 4 and now you can see that
thom
is on the way here if you know now who
can get some air is coming the
rook was here a must still have the two
king c2 would simply follow bishop four
i can briefly be a king with two
bishops a4  and black command access
king the two and now just thoma 2
and there is nothing to see like here
think sensibly at this moment
black time so in any case here
enough to play against and at least
to play for him so black court
strong against playing with so 8  on
springer that i played here he played that
and the move is just stronger
now like 5 comes straight away
and in this s  position caruana has
now played g4
maybe that's a good
move
too is quite certain a good move here
I would have liked it now though
now he five is also very good
because the access here now
covers the b4-square purely prophylactically and
yes if black now  playing
four could simply beat with that then
so this queen move exploited
this weakness of the c5-square and
white controls the
position very nicely it is not so easy to
see how black is supposed to get quickly
against play against the white
king and how to  because the
game will see yes black got a lot of play against the king i
think that is a is a very good
alternative if black was not too bad to b4
if black would capture
here now it is an important
little trick white has the strongest  move
b65 is now hanging and also c7 with the pawn captures
7 because it will be
an extraordinary sta  rken keep pawns on
27 that should probably be
won directly so black can't capture
in f5 g4 has among other things protected
the walls of the five so c5 would have protected the walls of the five so
i
like the move better
than g4 is
well liked  but not necessarily
bad it's just sharper because
black now how much actually
gets the a line open and
yes get a lot of games i think it was
better yes white has to take and black
yes indirectly the first row with the tower
yes and that  can already the tw1 looks
very logical but of course
not exactly what I
wanted to jump also the basic direction
to withdraw that will happen here
if white would have gone back with the ski jumper
which is admittedly
strange exposure
black wins immediately and with c3
sex c3 there  and the
tiger's leap to a3, yes, you win the game immediately,
so you can do this very quickly
with white auc  h lose well that's why
this move and now it's
already clear that black got a
bit of play he
sacrificed two pawns but in this
respect it
shouldn't necessarily be an advantage
at all but in any case to pose a
lot of problems so now jump since
I'm here  makes sense the knight
on 11 6 always threatens
to be attacked with g5 anyway and
so black also activates the rook
right here on the fourth row
so you can now play f6 i think
a good move for black's king
here in distress
there were also alternatives to bring, for example
the c6 was also very
conceivable to really use the rook here now,
for example
on the dined
so the six was a reasonable
alternative but also 11 6 was
certainly strong were black
king also got in a bit of
trouble and especially when
time is getting tight it's always
helpful that you a  also sometimes what can make the
king not clear to me because I do
n't know how the exact
time distribution was but it is clear
that both of them had little time here that
's that was clear to me I don't
know exactly how many minutes or seconds
it really was but  time there
was definitely clear in the game already
here and later even more extreme on 11 6
I played suffering now back then
and briefly look at the alternatives
what happens if black
hits 6 possible that wasn’t
particularly good but possible so
the 6 stands  example is really bad
here and in fact simply
swapping the queens and then rook panarea 1
sven Schwarze here is forced
to swap the tone yes, which unfortunately is the case, there
is a pretty desolate endgame
white still has one pawn more
but above all
the  black has structure here
it is extremely
extremely bad here on the
queenside the pawn on cbs weak
on this 1  4 7 and also white
always has the simple idea toni
sie so the position is as good as
lost for black he can't
capture with the queen on 6 he admits it was more possible but here too white should have better chances  have is very clear but not
to h1 damir 7 eg
and now the black queen can still
and probably donate in the white camp for
example the white now does not hastily
beat to 11 6 because the three rook the
two the only move with gmd once and
now confirms  b1 would win for black ground
so black
also has a lot of tricks here and
it's not super clear it should actually
be a bit better maybe
because he drew sex f6 but played stronger
than that which is envy
but at that time eight of course was a completely
plausible move  with the ec
here to start the very long jump
after two
years black has real attack so
a completely understandable move
caruana game  t now dame f3
more a defensive move that i can understand well
maybe would have known but hereby
heftrich g7
could get a very big advantage
i'm always a bit careful here
in my choice of words because i
may have
analyzed the game at the time and more on  let the computer
help but it's so complicated
that you can easily overlook
it
the idea of ​​the move is when black
plays 2 now back then which looks
pretty terrible at first
glance then more 1 has hangs has
white because announces a very strong move  the 2
and the remarkable thing is that now
the move knight c3 is just
threatening and will then come pretty
sure, after which suddenly the white
king is more legally secure on the two
and the knight on c3 wonderfully
covers all squares and black stands
for the high jump ac3 yes  maximally
unhappy black would probably
have to pull back the queen and then
white could just like that  what play like
g5 with the idea there after 11 6
or objection ac3 as already mentioned
and maybe because h 6 is a reason for
the 25 so for example now with it
after the 6 3
and in the position white should
be winning  now has 44
pawns, we no, three pawns more,
but the king is slowly starting
to stand securely again on the 2, the
whole thing is far less dangerous, even
if it has disappeared in the form of a board,
which white has done, so I think a
better continuation than the game,
though  it was all damn hard
so just hit the sugar seven times
back
in this position is
already extraordinarily cold-blooded
so f3 was played and
black went back after eight with the
back then to check the line
here black had
an alternative thome 5 which is
possibly  also stronger, but
it's
not easy  tes
makes moves like g5 in order to
advance further on the kingside here,
then black now comes back to back
then 2
and something like that is to be taken very seriously
against playing because it can
also lose very quickly, for
example with the c30
b1 rook w15 and white  gives up
so the whole
position is definitely still dangerous for white
and the four is probably
advisable here to attack the rook directly
on e5
and I have black
can simply capture the five
and
this position, for example,
is
after c3
strong move
wc then two
so g5 of
course hair-raising so
probably you almost almost get off the
chair of the have to play the six
then extra 1 the whole thing ends in a
perpetual check so quite confused and
complicated variants here the game with
scarce time as good as not
to be played at all  are reasonable so
tournament 5 was possibly stronger
but envious of mi 8 dam  i
can understand it very well
now caruana has played c3 with it
and sometimes defensively we
have to cover the dammen wing i think to cover
whereupon
direct played eight again back
then so i would certainly have nothing against
repeating the moves here
because the f3 is also playing  and
back yes now but
havana is playing to win don't want to make a
draw rightly so however the
breeding thurnherr 1 he played
here is not the best
he could now city tome f1 with
somehow i can my agent
lost in the overview
he
could play the train the six here
and that would have held the advantage i think i know
it is but really
murderous murderous complicated for
example cd six tower the
63 back to the 1 ups and the 1
thome 22 so a computer
feels good but it  it's damn hard to
play so
you can move to f1 then you can nail it for
is whole  normal move,
yes, only that unfortunately has a snag now
continuity bishop a14 what he didn't do
made the c5 but
bishop four was very strong here and
that will really lead to
strong black attacks hint
just can be had
if white for example now greedy  is
and if she doesn't beat rb7 with the rb7 then play no
black romy three and then comes
to the second row with
terrible threats against 12
and that can go down very quickly here
if, for
example, she discovers the building as she position is
already lost there  I ca
n't save them anymore the two is still the
best defense comes toni 11 and
thomik b1 and that's the brutal
thing about the position here everything comes with check
flown
king back then four check
with
it and everything is lost and black
wins that would be  stop happens when
casseroles a4
beats seen here, he can defend himself better
methods f2 and
this variant to the  game here
probably goes out of fc 2 for me and
then again the strange move c3
which further opens the position here bc
tower
d11 tomato 2 now we see the idea of
this whole action with c3 black has
exposed the second row and attacks
to 2 if  white would now try to protect
the pawn sideways with thom
the two
now end very quickly
with the last small mat so that
doesn't work and why c2 are
protected because it has the crazy move knight a3 to protect the pawn the idea it
for black  now beats g5
if in between mat
and crazy way is after hoenigs b2
here
bishop simple two of thomas
caught black has to do this separate
advice thome 1 white on the
button and wins you can
check with computer help a3 hangs and
the bishop c2 hangs too  and in the end,
weisweiler and attack had a
complicated game, in
fact, it would very likely be the case that
no one else would ever play a  went out but runs
four is again a very
difficult move with little time here
bishop 4 was good it came but g5
makes some space for the king and of
course he
prevents trick g7
and here
the camera plays with it three
is a completely plausible move with the
edf after e1 to get the line
I think yes on the line against play
and to get rid of
the gymnasts it was better however with three we now see the igs the same we
see why there is a problem with three
black plays thome 3
and now white begins yes  actually the
crucial mistakes the game had
to have two back then simply because no one
else is available with the
fdp 1 and relief in the line
actually came the f3 and
here jealously with very little time on the
clock I think played very strong and 2
and that  is now extremely
dangerous refers the position is
already tactically lost but
it is anything but easy
to see everything that is actually threatening here if
white, for example, makes a move like h4 the
summer does not change anything in the figure setting
then black comes with the very
strong move there I am around the
corner and threatens very dull mate on 10 2
and how should  know that now prevent
if he draws tom c3, for example,
forerunner 4 stands again on 10
2 on it and again
the two did to cover
and then stands up this previously
shown motif again
and at the end there is one with the
idea thoma 1  does what white can no longer
prevent
so black gets
two deadly attacks here after
tommy the best defense
is still gomez 2 that he also plays
then needs four runners again
so far so far black has done an excellent job
on 11.3 and now we can see
why the whole thing  Being at all
problematic is because at first
you might not see how
black is progressing, but he is
progressing with tor sc  bad as a
shadow
king bishop c2 beats everything with chess
king c1 the only move
dvd 1
king g1 not a big choice yes and
now it is black's move and played with
driving wins so the tempo here on
the yes on the white queen
does not now either  just many
possibilities has played canada
more 5 also makes sense threatening directly on g5
if we would run backwards
afterwards 1 for example the long
move then comes four check and
after for example king d2 d3 check
and 2 with it
counts the black attack just wanted to follow up
at home the ladies are already winning
and I think that makes it
more 5 makes a lot more sense because it
also threatens the five yes and
here are 36 in front of a move,
that means
four more moves until the fortieth at the
time control
and this makes you jealous  unfortunately discovered an
error
namely with h6 there is not
yet the win from the hand covers with
h6 the pawn g5 and
that's a pity because here could  e
here he could instead with the move
that was not wanted
with the move thome 1 chess
actually win the game relatively easily
however I think massive time with
the game white plays yes has to be king to
king d2 is after e3 check
immediately makes
yes so  king co2
then everything goes with
achim king c3
so b38 king d
4d 18 king c5
name e3 shaft king c6 and so b6
yes and in the end the king is
shot here he played
heartily actually
surprisingly sure you can't calculate all this
train traffic there
you don't have to
fool yourself no one can
still strikes me as funny when i think
i would have made the principle rw because there
are so many chess it's hard
to believe that what comes out of it you
look at this chess hail hemme
but maybe he has
seen a ghost somewhere and if you only have
seconds on the clock it
's not easy
6 takes also wears out against matter
and white's king is still
bad so black is
still better here after a6 it's just
not an immediate win anymore
so anja
caruana is now playing b5 with nothing on
the clock that you could see very
little time
instead
gymnastics club who is the better  move
after which white still has decent chances
after
b 5 what he played naiditsch
could win again with
practically the same idea since more than
king to two now no
longer a4 chess back then but with
5 there is what threatened four chess back then
or so that the triple optional and
the sticking point is when white comes to 288
has tommy eight
maybe he didn't see them conceivable these
long tower moves are always easy to
overlook yes and here loses because it
just
took mp3 and so on with white
or loses pretty much
everything about legendary pieces so the c1
would have won here again on b5
played d  he kills me i
really suspect with nothing on the clock that
's even better for black yes so by
no means
already decide then f3 and here
again romy wins 1
because king to
235 so that we five leads to the same
position as him or almost the same
position but is the gymnastics club but it
doesn't make any difference because with three
shafts he didn't win but unfortunately he
didn't make it
but in the position we took five
directly
or proof of the move with the strong
move when he was 39 all attention if
symptoms 2 found where  proof
no more direct loses than
at least don't sit math or something like that,
yes, there might have been another
chance here instead of the
five he played
, two towers are still possible
where later queens have to follow two each
king 2 just there I want to 28
there we have 2 so g5 beats check
yes because the king has to move then
for example king on 7
we now reach the queen  endgame with a
black sea of ​​pawns and possibly
you can get it with king g6 sun then
moved the pawn f6 so i
would argue that black has
better chances of winning here than in a
rook ending that
arises in the game but not easy to
say so black should  he's still in a
much better position
I'd say but
whether it's won directly
I can't say right now without telling
myself that the hour was
playing so the five were probably
his 39 so I know for sure more than a
little time swapping them  since i
must be happy that he no longer makes is
king to two years only reached this
topic into the game i have mentioned i
have compared to that since more here
has white i think much clearer
counterplay us soon with the ideas the
tower marie 7 too  bring as
shown graphically or stop with the king
on c2 yes attacking the tree on c4 and
direct opponent on the queen's floor  to get wings
and i think that
black has chances of winning here
the computer, for example, the
position is also quite balanced
there is black 0.1 something and you
can see relatively quickly
how the game is going on that there are
hardly any alternatives here black he
has to take away the pawn here and white
gets 7 and as already mentioned
through the active king on c4 then
reach will happen pretty much
i think
this endgame where the baby belly will bind
very fast and the black rook
than this looks very logically
black  must hurry with the tower
to stop the pawn here
yes here was another possibility the
black ford f 5 pulls where proof
runs hand with the king and the problem is
that the beaver binds completely in thon
and as soon as the black king to the
pawn  above it runs rook and king of
white who will pick up pawns so here
black can try to run but
because it can just block here and
black doesn't get any further
i think it was easy it's a
game so good maybe
someone will watch it for a few hours and find
something but
i can't really believe it in
the game like i said no king  f6
and white then just ran up
to the pawns here with the king
and yes we
achieve the most
comfortable all draw position
to the bell king yes more exciting than and
20 swift remy of which many
past tournaments work enough seen and
I think it is a very good decision
that this  anti draw rule applies here
again and here
you can also see such really
great fight games yes a pity for
envious the big one had more than one great
chance of winning at the time
but you have to say that he also before that I think
as good as lost times
overall, as I said, there was a great
fight,
the other
striking and enjoyable game
today because of you  g by georg
maier against a matter stadler from
poland the game showed
that one will also have been a winning game
for the german player but
i did
n't want to miss the exciting tactical complications of the game
but meyer's game is
also very easy to replay  values ​​very
nice very nice victory from the
Catalan opening with white
yes there were also three draws which
I think were fairly uneventful the
German duel friedman against gustafsson
was always in hmi width maybe
always
symbolically a bit better for daniel
friedman but actually I think
there was almost never anything going on
lego often tried to win against annemarie quite
calm variation calm variation im
assuming queens
but i don't think we could make any
serious progress
and then we had the
most attractive pairing of the day on paper karjakin
against Kramnik I think the two
ratin  if i'm not
mistaken the cabana and the jackets are
five points apart if at all
in any case the ones in the kajak game,
on the other hand, a thriller came out relatively
quickly
i think there was a new opening
idea tried by kajak, but it didn't really bring
much either  scottish
and so dar and 20 25 10
practically everything was exchanged and then you played
remy by repeating it yes well
that was the first video about the
dortmund shaft days i think
tomorrow will be the next one i
hope for about one  exciting game and
yes i look forward to comments and
suggestions
on the video
and will probably say goodbye to
bayern tomorrow